Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học Đỗ
Bảo Nam Brock video ngày hôm nay Đỗ Bảo
Nam Brock sẽ chia sẻ với bạn cách viết
chỉ số dưới trong Word Viết công thức
hóa học trong
Word và ở nội dung video này đ bà Nam
Block sẽ chia sẻ với bạn ba cách thực
hiện trong đó Cách thứ nhất và cách thứ
hai là những cách nhanh và đơn giản bây
giờ mình sẽ đi vào từng cách
một cách thứ nhất đó là dùng phím tắt
Ctrl cộng phím Bằng ví dụ bây giờ mình
sẽ viết công thức đó là
H2O thì đầu tiên bạn nhập cái nội dung
công thức bình
thường và để viết chỉ số dưới bạn nhấn
tổ phím là Ctrl cộng
bằng khi đó bạn nhìn thấy dấu nhai chuột
đã thu nhỏ lại ở phía
dưới bây giờ mình sẽ nhập số
2 và sau đó để chuyển trạng thái nhập
văn bản về Bình thườ thường bạn lại nhấn
tổ phím Ctrl cộng phím bằng như vậy bây
giờ mình có thể nhập văn bản như bình
thường tiếp theo mình sẽ sang Cách thứ
hai đó là Click vào icon X2 ở trên thanh
rb đó chính là icon
này thì đầu tiên mình vẫn viết cái nội
dung bình thường trước
đã sau đó bạn Click vào cái icon X2
này và bạn Nhập chỉ số
dưới sau khi viết chỉ số dưới xong để
trở về trạng thái bình thường thì bạn
lại Click vào cái icon I2 này và bây giờ
mình sẽ nhập nội dung bình thường như
vậy là
[âm nhạc]
xong Tiếp theo mình sẽ sang Cách thứ ba
đó là dùng hộp thoại phông trong Word
cách này thao tác Thực hiện phức tạp hơn
so với hai cách trên do vậy theo mình
tốt nhất bạn có thể thực hiện theo hai
cách này và ở đây mình vẫn demo Cách thứ
ba đầu tiên mình vẫn nhập nội dung bình
thường trước sau đó bạn có thể nhấn tổ
phím Ctrl d để mở h đại
phông hoặc bạn cũng có thể nhấn tồ phím
đó là Ctrl C shift c f tổ phím này cũng
để mở h loại
phông sau đó bạn tích vào cái dòng
subscript và Ok như vậy bạn thấy dấu
nháy chuột đã được đưa xuống cái phần
phía dưới này và bạn có thể nhập chỉ số
dưới sau khi nhập chỉ số dưới xong bạn
lại nhấn Ctrl d để mở hộ rại phông và
bạn bỏ tích ở cái phần
subscript và Click vào ok như vậy dấu
nháy chuột của mình đã chuyển về trạng
thái bình thường và bây giờ mình có thể
nhập văn bản như lúc
đầu và như vậy Ở nội dung video này đố B
Nam blog vừa chia sẻ nhanh với bạn ba
cách để viết chỉ số dưới Viết công thức
hóa học trong ố trong đó Cách thứ nhất
và cách thứ hai là hai cách nhanh đơn
giản
nhất Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin
chào và hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các video tiếp
theo
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích Bạn hãy nhấp chuột vào like và chia
sẻ video để ủng hộ Đỗ bà Nam Block đồng
thời Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ bà Nam
Block Bạn hãy nhấp chuột vào nút đăng ký
và chọn hình
chuông nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và
nhận thêm các video hữu ích từ đỗ bào
Nam Block Xin cảm ơn các
bạn Ngoài ra bạn có thể tìm kiếm trên
Google với từ khóa Đỗ bào Nam
blog và truy cập vào website doob.com
hoặc kênh YouTube Đỗ bàn h blog để xem
thêm các video hữu ích như thủ thuật máy
tính Style pro prer cách sử dụng các
phần mềm như Word Excel PowerPoint vân
vân và bạn có thể truy cập Website là
doban blog.com để cập nhật những bài
viết hữu ích mới
nhất Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin
chào và hẹn Hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các video
tiếp theo